tout d'abord vous videz bien votre
vessie ensuite vous nettoyez vos mains
avec le savon vous rincez bien vous
séchez bien vos mains vous désinfectez
vos mains et votre verge avec une petite
compresse désinfectante
et voilà
avec les petites flèches ou sélectionner
ce que vous voulez comme type
donc Claude dit que les actrices ont
besoin d'amour il dit que vous Elsa vous
avez besoin d'amour dans des proportions
anormales est-ce que vous pourriez nous
illustrer s'il vous plaît c'est
proportion normal
[Rires]
[Musique]
mes états
comment dire c'est je pense quand on est
actrice on est au contraire on est enfin
moi je pense que dès lors on est plus
dans la vie on n'est plus actrice moi je
suis très dans la vie je pense qu'il
faut être dans la vie parce que sinon tu
peux plus jouer et en fait moi je suis
très curieuse je suis alors Claude une
belle chose j'aime tellement Claude
Lelou j'ai dit le oui est toujours plus
porteur je trouve que dans la vie quand
on dit non bah il se passe rien
ce jour là Alice a jeté environ le quart
de ce qu'elle a acheté
et même ce qu'elle a mis de côté elle
n'est pas sûr de le vendre
000 balles pour une story quelle n'a
sûrement pas écrit elle-même et derrière
ça vient nous faire des leçons de morale
sur le travail et les forts
les blancs vous les insultez oui vous me
faites perdre de l'argent et vous voulez
que je souris
[Musique]
salut
c'est l'un des bidons villes les plus
pollués au monde dans la capitale du
Ghana le quartier d'Old Fadama est
surnommé la poubelle de l'Occident
déjà j'aimerais vous féliciter parce que
si
on écoute des gens comme vous qui êtes
tournés vers le passé ben en fait on va
droit dans le mur voilà donc
on peut pas prendre un café sans avoir
une guêpe sur ses couilles là
c'est pas moi qui fait les courses parce
que j'aime pas ça et puis
c'est quand même
[Musique]
environ 100000 personnes vivent ici dans
l'extrême pauvreté autour d'une montagne
de déchets
ou plastique des restes de nourriture
mais surtout c'est couche de vêtements
usagées qui ont fait le tour du monde
avant d'atterrir ici comment vous faites
pour baisser la pollution et bah c'est
les voitures arrêtées
les poussières fines c'est les gaz
d'échappement vous avez fait une
politique
vous rendez compte le nombre de magasins
qui sont obligés de fermer à cause de
vous parce qu'il y a des travaux devant
des contre le nombre de chauffeurs de
taxis de chauffeurs qui sont dans la
merde c'est à cause de vos conneries là
il y a des abeilles et des guêpes qu'il
faut protéger
ça veut dire quoi comme maintenant avec
ma sœur on a choisi d'être honnête et de
quitter l'alliance en bonne uniforme et
ben ça justifie le fait s'en prendre à
nous comme ça
pourquoi il y a autant de guêpes à Paris
pourquoi c'est quoi l'histoire
climatique
Émile
jusqu'à
un menteur Émile
[Applaudissements]
à 19h45
vous avez pas enlever la les trucs là
sur les toiles là les trucs là n'importe
quoi
bien sûr il y a des ruches exactement
mais voilà les abeilles c'est juste
à chaque fois que je vais prendre un
café j'ai des abeilles autour de moi
parce que vous avez fait vous avez [ __ ]
par image là on est plus dans le pissure
original là on est dans le privilège
blanc biologique c'est-à-dire que quoi
que vous fassiez Pascal vous êtes
raciste et donc la religion wok oui
comme ça c'est parce que vous êtes blanc
oui non c'est ça il faut dire les choses
c'est comme ça que c'est que que cette
religion s'impose c'est de plus en plus
n'importe quoi l'assemblée après les
invectives et les sorties de l'hémicycle
nouvel incident aujourd'hui je te
souhaite
voilà ce qui peut se passer trouver des
objets originaux composés le 01 74
84 74 34 je sais plus et nous avons ici
un petit ustensile que je vous présente
qui s'appelle une gourde je tenais à
dire que c'était possible de boire
autrement qu'avec une bouteille d'eau
j'ai rangé mon instrument monsieur le
Président
l'instrument était une gourde et pour la
petite info pour briller en ville les
gourdes sont interdites dans l'hémicycle
de même que les bouteilles d'eau on ne
peut pas boire
[Musique]
je suis le roi
le roi des